you know of all the established
directors working today I think the one
that would feel most at home in my world
the world of the video essay is Edgar
right see basically what I do here every
week like any essayist is make an
argument the difference between me and
say New York Times columnist Paul
Krugman besides a PhD in economics and
like accolades is that I use video to
make my arguments where he has only
language but even so our goals are the
same to make a persuasive and engaging
argument and just like writers pay close
attention to the flow of their words
carefully crafting the transitions from
one idea to the next
I see the rhythm and momentum of my
videos as crucial to their effectiveness
and here's where I can learn a lot from
a guy and I get back to it Edgar Wright
is a master of rhythm what you just saw
is one of many extraordinary scene
transitions from Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world it lasts about four and a half
seconds but it's worth taking a second
slower look this transition is all about
movement to the right it kicks off with
Anna Kendrick looking to camera right
which is the direction of the movement
but she's also looking at her brother
through the split screen her split
screen is keyframed
off to the left and so is Scott pilgrims
but Wright has cleverly positioned him
left in the frame so he can bring in the
unseen right-hand part of the shot to
extend the dolly wipe and the right of
that frame is the armchair which wipes
across to reveal the next outdoor
setting and the UH nimona peel letters
of the school bell ade this transition
into a shot that continues the motion by
actually dollying to the right if you
were to diagram out this transition it
would look a little like this and it
gives you a better sense of just how
much care is put into a handful of
frames the transitions are a sight of
opportunity for Edgar Wright they're not
only an opportunity for visual jokes as
my friend Tony explored briefly in
another video which I'll link to right
here they're a chance to build important
connective tissue that brings the viewer
through the story in fact I think a
story is a lot like an argument it has
to be persuasive to work
Scot what he only played one note for
that entire song in the beginning of
this movie Scott Pilgrim is adrift the
break-up that defined his life for the
past year is no longer an excuse for his
sour attitude he begins a relationship
with a 17-year old that's clearly not
serious to him and he's kind of just
floating through life it's a feeling
that I'm sure a lot of people are
familiar with I know I am when
everything sort of melts together and
you skip around in time from place to
place to communicate this feeling right
melts together the transitions between
settings he utilizes a few techniques to
do this on Scott's date with knives for
example there are a series of frame
wipes that use diegetic moving objects
usually people that are so seamless they
momentarily trick the brain into not
registering the transition what's more
these wipes are all accompanied by sound
effects which are also diegetic whether
it's a car a skateboard the rustling of
clothes hangers or the beep of a sliding
door all pulling you deeper into the
world
you also have shots where the reverse
shot is matched in framing but in a
totally different location I mean this
is really cool because Wright is using
the rules of cinema against you you're
not trained to think that a scene
transition could come between a shot
River shot so you're already engaging
with the next place before you realize
that you've left the last one when you
think back on this sequence it's hard to
remember all the locations as distinct
which is exactly what Scott is feeling I
told you like 50 times oh and it's party
retard all throughout Scott Pilgrim
right never misses a chance to use a
creative transition whether it's from
scene to scene oh hey it's tonight
at the or within scenes from shot to
shot I think the overall effect of this
is to full not only do the wipes and
whip pans and match cuts draw you along
the story as it unfolds but they also
make you into a more observant viewer
there are transitions that disappear the
first time you watch and stand out the
second time or vice versa
I mean where exactly is the scene
transition here it's happening
completely off screen or rather behind
the screen my guess is either that
how set is on wheels or the bathroom
itself is being spun around to face
another backdrop whichever it is the
transition is disorienting in the best
way and because what's happening isn't
possible you're encouraged to sort of
put the film together and interactivity
that's appropriate and a movie about
gaming what's important is that the film
goer is involved and engrossed at the
same time this delicate balance is
achieved through transitions that are
often lyrical like a kind of visual
poetry in the most unlikely place it
might be worth noting too that Scott
Pilgrim is a story about a transitionary
period in the hero's life a period
between knowing who you were and
deciding who you're going to be life's
transitions are harder to navigate than
those in film or a video essay but all
of them have to be persuasive and
persuasion is about more than the words
or the images or the ideas you use it's
also about how you connect now
hey everybody thanks for watching there
is a new nerdwriter episode every
Wednesday so if you click right there
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all the videos guys I'm in Venice can
you see can you see that I'm in Venice
Italy that is amazing I'm here for a
month and a half working living
exploring it's this place is like a
dream and being here is a dream for me
anyway I have to thank Squarespace for
sponsoring this video they make sleek
intuitive websites I just made one
called the nerdwriter net you sign up
for a year you can get a free domain
name and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter you can get 10% off your
first purchase up you know it's really
easy to do go make one it's fun thanks
guys for that and I will see the rest of
you hopefully next Wednesday